so the greatest mathematical minds of
all ages from Pythagoras and Euclid in
ancient Greece through the many evil
Italian that edition than out of Pisa
the Renaissance astronomer Johannes
Kepler to present-day side two fears
that such as Oxford businesses Roger
Penrose has spent endless hours over
this simple ratios and its properties
but the fascination with God nature is
not confined just to mathematicians list
all these different people they've all
pondered and debate the basis of its
ubiquity that means it's everywhere
ubiquity is something that's ubiquitous
it's all over the place and appeal in
fact is probably fair to say the golden
ratio has inspired thinkers of all
disciplines no other lover by in the
history of mathematics I now I wonder if
you can see why I decided to start here
okay now just look at this quite for a
second but you computers there yeah open
up Excel yep missus are there people who
are interested in like philosophy and
things like you can't be major and
religious people now there's a these are
makes you around a few names on there
right
but there's one name in particular which
you probably didn't recognize even
though you know exactly who he is
up here you like another Pisa that's not
that's not da Vinci you want to be Jesus
lean unto be see here the reason why you
don't recognize him is because he was
learned by a more common name namely hip
adduction that was the name - gone okay
now
Fibonacci he's not doing I'm taking the
dining up swing a little bit okay
Fibonacci has this guy buried in Hume
right
to illustrate this what I could do is
get you to get a calculator out and then
machine out the numbers and all that
kind of thing but that's a bit boring
and you guys have technology he's sir
you've got excelled in now hands up and
it's okay if none of you do how many of
you have ever opened up Excel that's the
first question okay so most of you
all right that's fine keep it keep your
hand up if you've actually used it for
something substantial yeah okay good
right now keep your hands up if you've
actually input any formulas into it
all right good so hands down let's see
how we fare with this we're gonna build
the Fibonacci series tends to be called
F 1 F 2 F 3 and so on now to do it
here's what you do
the first two numbers in the Fibonacci
sequence are defined right they are
picked out and they are the first one
and one right there we go now by the way
just for what it's worth you don't have
to start with 1 and 1 you can stop with
different numbers and you get different
series about something you can work up a
little now how am I gonna build a
Fibonacci sequence what's the rule that
makes the Fibonacci sequence
yep that's right a follow the third one
I take the first or second or anemometer
this is not hard to do it yourself you
say equals to start you're crazy this is
familiar and then you say I'll take that
cell you can read the coordinates right
age suit ok and then I'm going to add
the cell beneath it
simple HT plus a3 okay and you get the
mind-blowing result of two you're like
wow technology it's amazing okay right
now here's where the magic starts the
great thing about this formula and if
you put your cursor over it you can see
the formula reappear in that top bar
okay the magic of the formula is that if
I just copy this formula the a to the a3
they retain their their what I would
call their relative meaning which is add
up the one to about me and the one one
above me okay so if I copy that if you
copy it if you just paste it into the
next cell
you get three right because if you
double click now double click on that
three right while it will reveal is look
see I'm looking at the previous two so
they're highlighted become as therefore
you blue and green in the defaults now
that means it that what we can do is
message analyze you can copy this
formula or if you like to be fancy
you drag that a little square and you
can paste it down as many times as you
like I'd like you to go up to a bath
buddy so when you faced in wallah you've
got one of these terms now stay with me
Excel can go much further than that
which is correct hundreds and hundreds
ideas but this is we far enough to
illustrate the point all right now
you've got another column over okay in
this column rather than work out terms
the Fibonacci sequence okay we're gonna
work out a ratio the ratio I'm
interested in is from one Fibonacci
number to the next one
one number to the next okay so how do I
write that out obviously this no bikini
it doesn't have a previous one so I'm
not gonna worry about you starting it up
to be cities with the slash style okay
is that right say equals right and then
you say one number and I'm gonna divide
it by the previous one okay so it's just
like what you're doing before with
addition but here I've got the slash for
division okay again you press ENTER you
get the bolt off but let's keep going
okay now don't do it all at once okay
just for the sake of it
I just want you to call you you paste it
once you like okay - I dig do you paste
it again will you get three Oh - 3 / -
that's my one in the heart right now
when you paste it again something
interesting happens right something
interesting happens it starts to
converge on something it starts to
converge on something quite quickly -
now you've done a few okay I want you to
go down to that whatever was there
something like that okay and you go
ahead and you paste the mini
so you can you can copy any one of these
cells here your ratio color and then
just paste it down now you can see this
is this is why I say I can stop if
anything you're like what what what just
happened what just happens
the golden ratio just happened no he's
the question for you and I'm not gonna
answer for you I want you to think about
it why why why why why why remember I
said this is the question you asked to
help you think deeply about simple
things okay it's bad it's not a
coincidence nothing in Madison is a
coincidence so why why is it a period
yes
you mean wants to go up in it if you
have a look
pay careful attention you will see from
one to the next there's a kind of
oscillating thing that happens can you
see look this one is higher up but then
this one is lower then the next one
did you see what's going on right so
excited to do it this way this will be
lower then it goes up then it goes down
it goes up again and down and it's kind
of its kind of doing this it's doing
this as this kind of behavior it's
oscillating so it does look a bit
unusual but it's homing in it is homing
in inexorably - in fact if I were to
draw this rap this number would be five
okay show me yeah bingo there you go in
fact let's do that shall we let's all do
it that's a great idea you can take all
of these alright well you can take quite
a few of them right and and you can see
it homes in really fast right and it
does that wiggling thing just like I
modeled here okay pretty cool